qui es-tu personne en particulier
ce qui nous amène à ce que toi tu penses
d'un désert que j'ai devant moi un mec
qui se prend pour l'incarnation du
diable
ce qui s'est passé dans le désert il ya
eu un problème vient tueur après mois
mais qu'est ce que je vois là et célèbre
mon frère
dual enfants et une femme magnifique mon
frère
qu'est ce que tu peux tout ce que tu as
de toute façon je vais te tuer tu veux
qu'on jour olatz mon frère je suis pas
ton frère être ou le passé
c'est toujours la même question
cet endroit est dangereux il faut que tu
te mettre en sécurité
tout a commencé dans le désert
dauphine ira là bas qu'est ce que tu
attends à la grande aventure
ben oui laquelle la mort